este 3 de mayo se cumplen 30 años de la
declaración de wing fuck realizada por
periodistas de medios africanos en 1991
esta declaración toma su nombre de la
capital de namibia sólo dos años después
en 1993 la propia unesco declaró el 3 de
mayo como día mundial de la libertad de
prensa pero 28 años después de la
declaración la libertad de los
informadores para ejercer su profesión
está sufriendo un paulatino deterioro
según la ong reporteros sin fronteras el
73 por ciento de los 180 países que
analiza cada año tiene la libertad de
prensa total o parcialmente bloqueada el
ejercicio del periodismo principal
vacuna contra el virus de la
desinformación encuentra graves
impedimentos en 73 de los 180 estados
del ranking establecido por reporteros
sin fronteras y obstáculos en otros 59
destacan por la buena calidad de su
libertad de prensa noruega finlandia y
suecia mientras que en el fondo de la
lista encontramos a türkmenistán corea
del norte y eritrea como países con
menor libertad de prensa este año además
son ya ocho los periodistas asesinados
en cumplimiento de su labor según
la ong los últimos los españoles david
beriáin y roberto fraile en burkina faso
recientemente se han dado casos también
de arrestos de periodistas en mianmar
tras el golpe militar y el
enjuiciamiento en hong kong de la
periodista va 8 y por supuesta
realización de declaraciones falsas
desde la fundación para la libertad de
prensa se denunciaron el domingo
agresiones contra periodistas en
colombia durante las recientes protestas
en la flip conocimos 18 agresiones
contra la prensa en el contexto de las
manifestaciones del primero de mayo la
fuerza pública nuevamente fue el
principal agresor el informe de
reporteros sin fronteras muestra que los
indicadores de libertad de prensa
empeoraron por el cierre de accesos a
fuentes y coberturas durante la pandemia
queda por ver si se recuperarán cuando
ésta termine